We Begin this morning with a significant
development from the January 6th house
committee investigating the capital
riots as first reported by Politico the
committee will recommend unprecedented
criminal charges against former
president Donald Trump on Monday it will
refer at least three charges to the
Department of Justice against the former
president along with detailed
justifications for them Christina
raffini is in our Washington Bureau with
the very latest Christina good morning
good morning Dana will after 10 hearings
the committee is making its final
recommendations which could also include
referrals to charge other former members
of Trump's Inner Circle like former
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows and
confidante Rudy Giuliani
that the central cause of January 6th
was one man Donald Trump after
interviewing more than a thousand
Witnesses about the events leading up to
the riot of the capitol
the January 6 committee will reportedly
vote in favor of recommending the
justice department bring charges against
former president Trump we're going to
walk down to the Capitol I'm not going
to jump ahead of the committee but I
just I will say that I think members
have become uh convinced that there's
value in it Committee Member
representative Zoe Lofgren says the
group will also make public the majority
of its findings only 98 or better of
what the committee records have been
compiled we intend to publish yeah the
potential charges against Trump include
Insurrection obstruction of an official
proceeding and conspiracy to defraud the
U.S government I think that they
conducted the business with the
seriousness it deserves the fact that
it's about our national security
more than 930 people have been charged
for their involvement in January 6th
including 43 year old Douglas Jensen one
of the most well-known faces of the day
seen here leading a mob in pursuit of
Capitol Police Officer Eugene Goodman
yesterday a judge sentenced him to five
years behind bars I think we're all
certainly in agreement that there is
evidence of criminality here on Face the
Nation last week representative Adam
Schiff declined to name who else could
be on the committee's Referral List
we're looking at what is the Quantum of
evidence that we have against
individuals what is the impact of making
a referral
also on Deck the house Ways and Means
Committee has been reviewing Trump's tax
records it could release those returns
or parts of them also early next week
Michelle
Christina thank you